welcome to this video playing Dorrit
from Germany yeah that's a teammate of
mine let's see what we get
I usually try to play something offbeat
against him okay let's let's play for
the for the hippo it's not a terrible
setup if white is not super aggressively
placed like he is here and it's so it's
not the best opening ever but probably
not the worst yeah playing all the
standard moves I'd like to get in c5 I
mean I really have this classical kind
of prep position I want points in the
center always even in those openings
where it is not supposed to be okay I'm
going for c5 and probably get get
clobbered some wood in the center I
always want you to push in the center
somehow okay if he goes Bishop f4 okay
h4 is this this is kind of direct h4 g5
he might sacrifice yeah that's that's
really that's really possible okay
maybe I'm going to take here first
maybe Knight f6 for possibly d5 like g5
e 594 for for a good knight on e4 maybe
on h5 I go g5 and I am not sure if he
can sacrifice a piece that I tend to not
believe that but it's not it's not
entirely clear admittedly okay I'm going
to put this this only for night only
four should be nice
and possibly Knight f5 Layton he cannot
really take their only form and it's
kind of annoying if he has to yeah this
was to be expected
I thought night at five now but maybe
this is not on ok I can take him I can
of course just take making a spawn
structure kind of miserable worship
chinks 9594 de for Bishop before should
take squint eggs
I don't have a convincing follow up
there Knight f5 an IG three and Knight
f5 is isn't is a possibility but it's
not very convincing
hmm I don't want to take on on g3 really
it looks it looks set load does not look
very healthy I have an idea
maybe that move Bishop if for de is
probably giving me compensation so this
could be an interesting little little
twist to things you just played rook c1
I have an interesting idea Knight e4 on
rook check c2 assistance
I drank to two big glasses of coke maybe
this is kind of kind of jack doping me
here in some way this is a strange idea
that happened maybe it is possible okay
Knight f6 yeah I have to check and then
then he will take C - mm-hmm okay so my
doping influenced idea wasn't really on
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so I'm a I'm an
exchange down what a shame it was a
funny idea Bishop takes a choice g4
right just an exchange down and what a
shame I really like that idea
hey but it didn't work okay just plays
g3 now keeping keeping things together
and to share my absolutely only hope is
somehow to activate this Bishop get it
get it on a Stewie for something
something like that but it's hard to
believe it's really this is really just
lost with good play for white
good play from white ah
I cannot go beautiful or anything I have
to have to retreat unfortunately and
this allows rook c7 not much I can do
about that
h5 takes Knight f5 is this possible
ok I need to I need some kind of
irritation here with normal moves I'm
going to lose so trying for that but he
probably can play Queen a form there is
no no real reason not to go there
Queen f4 he doesn't do that okay
checking here hmm I go Queen d8 is going
Bishop g5 so okay maybe just threatening
on f3 and d4
yeah of course I just you just have to
irritate the yyt a little bit trying to
as a friend of mine tears through dirt
Adam maybe this is some at least giving
me some practical chances okay I cannot
take really a chick here it's going to
take them okay I get that but I can take
twice here right Bishop takes Bishop
takes that see one hanging so we cannot
take it - rocky - bishop c1 so it's kind
of it's it's the kind of murky the
bishops are irritating time warning okay
so I can't I can't start with this right
and start with this more take there and
there will be three right and he maybe
threatens to take on these six b3 is
very irritating okay we should we should
be three five or something hmm I just
have 38 seconds
Queen e2 t2 this kind of thing I have to
toss the Queen and somehow if it works
or not it's not important I just have to
use the Queen here jack hmm this is
irritating this bishop
Queen f4 I think is good for white jack
but maybe winning for white Jack yeah or
that one only I can take the Rukia white
reasons oh wow yeah I've irritated him
to no end there from this rotten
position Wow
yeah but sometimes you you can just
muddy the waters and it's difficult to
play yeah rook takes it to was a fun
idea but it's just simply not working at
all absolutely not working
yeah so maybe I have to have to take
somewhere on d2 or d3 I don't know and
maybe this is still quite okay white is
probably better this is a nice idea but
it's not it's simply not working him to
Knight f6 this is fantastic
what was my idea but I didn't I forgot
that
that he saw 96 or overlooked yeah I tend
to confuse those those words yeah here I
mean I can I can play a pawn down but
it's really just just a pawn down so
probably I have to take somewhere yep
and then play this position like trying
to get this in H - yeah white is better
here
yeah to some extent I don't know how how
much you know I don't know if it is
worse than some kind of French structure
my King looks a bit shaky but with aged
5 and so on but it is still quite safe
with the bishop e8 covers stuff yeah and
the way it went okay I have some
pleasure and fell into this and now I'm
just down material and white could
probably have won a number of times but
okay I have to have to struggle on you
know here rook c7 is quite convincing
but okay what he did is certainly okay I
don't know that I don't think that this
is
any any problem or so the computer
points out H takes G 6 FG 6 Queen b6 for
Queen e6 yeah okay here I mean I'm still
lost but I kind of felt that this is at
least really murky ok 96 wins yeah I saw
the move of course but I thought that
Jackie this would maybe somehow hold he
can do this and then play b3 for the
rook yeah it is lost and what can you do
and here yeah it's already 0.5 here kind
of kind of unclear with with the Queen
and Jack yeah I got a I got a draw
no Queen III is good for white here
still I think if he goes King f2 here he
did oh no this is what I manage now here
and Jack not this but isn't Queen f4
good I can go here of course huh Jim his
King is this wide open I don't know
maybe this is good enough for a draw but
not very deserved for anything but maybe
it is yeah
shaky stuff thanks for watching